37 millions de personnes vivent avec le
vih dans le monde et même si l'accès aux
traitements évoluer progresse il ya
encore 40 % des malades dans le monde
qui n'ont pas accès aux traitements
solidays c'est dans moins de trois
semaines le festival en faveur de la
lutte contre le sida revient pour une
21e édition
c'est aussi un rendez-vous qu'on attend
tous parce que ça c'est un week-end qui
fait du bien c'est un week-end à terre
public c'est un week-end où on se sent
plus proche des autres où il ya de la
bienveillance de l'empathie ça me permet
d'assister à des colloques de rencontrer
des gens ou ensuite d'acheter des
bouquins intéressant qui nous permette
de grandir de m'éduquer et puis ensuite
de repasser à la musique il ya tout qui
est condensée dans ce festival cette
année encore l'ile-de-france et
partenaires un soutien à hauteur de 800
mille euros
la région est particulièrement touché
chaque jour 7 franciliens découvrent
leur séropositivité
nous avons un grand festival de musique
populaire française et ça est
indépendant et ça c'est très important
culturellement c'est très important
c'est un festival qui est un supplément
d'âme un supplément d'âme parce que la
question de la lutte contre le sida est
majeur tu l'as dit pour l'ile-de-france
80 concerts répartis sur 3 jours le
festival attire chaque année des
nouveaux artistes mais aussi des fidèles
hocus pocus se reforme pour une tournée
anniversaire
solidays c'est un des plus beaux
festivals qu'on ait fait on a vraiment
des souvenirs particuliers où on s'est
retrouvé à jouer dans quarante cinquante
mille personnes
on nous a souvent programmés sur des
débuts de projets aussi quand s'était
pas lancé par exemple sur alta où
c'était incroyable sous le chapiteau en
ce moment on est à fond sur l'engagement
c'est un truc qui est qu'on a compris
c'est un truc qui est venu avec le
succès et qu'on a compris en se disant
on a un gros audimat il ya des grands
enjeux en ce moment dans notre époque
actuelle donc il faut qu'on fasse partie
de ça pour être solidaire c'est du 21 au
23 juin à paris longchamp l'an dernier
le festival avait battu un record de
fréquentation plus de 212 mille
spectateurs s'étaient déplacés